what I am trying to do now is to
transform the Democratic body Bernie
Sanders has emerged as one of the most
popular politicians in the u.s. at this
moment at the same time a lot of your
progressive supporters aren't very happy
seeing you out on a unity tour with the
DNC they say this is a party that burned
you that undermined your campaign that
is not moving to the left that has not
learned it's lessons from the election
why waste your time on that okay I know
what happened during my campaign but I
also know what Trump and his extreme
right-wing billionaire friends are
capable of doing to this country so what
I am trying to do now is to transform
the Democratic Party transform it that
we're having some success some success
and that is make it into a grassroots
party where you come in you want to come
in you come in and you go to the
meetings and what's happening in
California progressives are gradually
taken over the Democratic body we're
seeing really good things in many parts
of this country come on in fight for a
progressive agenda and that's what I am
trying to do now now will I succeed I
can't give you an answer maybe I won't
maybe the resistance is social but I do
want to also say to you is somebody who
knows I think more about this than
anybody in Congress doing third party
politics is not so easy if you think oh
boy we don't like the Democrats we never
thought a third party and Wow when a
couple years maybe you know maybe but
that has not been the history of the
United States I wanted to ask you about
that your friend dr. Cornel West in
addition to people who worked on your
campaign have said let's leave the DNC
we need to go start this third party
this populist progressive People's Party
and we want senator Bernie Sanders at
the helm I love I love Cornel do you
accept the invitation no I don't right
now right now what I am trying to do is
to transform the Democratic Party now we
will see if we you know starting a third
party it is easy to spot it it is a lot
more difficult to make it into a strong
reality not just a historical thing I
know that a lot of the young people out
there are still feeling the Bern and
they'll follow you wherever wrong
question
I don't want them to follow me I want
them to follow their own instincts
you follow me and tomorrow somebody else
comes along that's not what democracy is
about I appreciate I was gonna say they
follow you if you start a new party I
appreciate you have you're the Democrat
understand and I appreciate the love and
support and it's mutual and there's
nothing that makes me happier you know
when I go around the country is seeing
this beautiful young people were ready
to get involved in an unprecedented way
and whatever way that turns out getting
involved it's not a top-down I don't
believe in top-down stuff I believe in
bottom on up stop people getting
involved in whatever way makes sense to
them into their communities based on
your long and complicated history in
American politics do you believe that a
two-party system is the most viable and
effective way to have an American
democracy no I don't but you know what
the problem is we are not a
parliamentary system of government and
that's not to say by any means that you
can't have three parties in the fuel
running in in Europe and your party got
five percent of the vote five percent
not a whole lot you would have seats in
the parliament depending on the country
in the United States you get five
percent of the vote
that's what you got it's like I said to
the book you got nowhere in a hurry if
there are people who think running is an
independent running is a third party
candidate makes sense do it but I think
right now where we are with the great
danger of Donald Trump and the
billionaire class and the reactionary
agenda they are up against I am right
now trying again well I do successful we
will say to transform the Democratic
Party in a very fundamental way so we
have just passed the 100-day mark of
trumps presidency what has surprised you
most about this presidency thus far his
total hypocrisy look I have dealt with
you know reactionaries who say look I
want to give tax breaks to billionaires
I want to cut Social Security Medicare
Medicaid education I've dealt with those
people but this is a guy who campaigned
for president saying I am a different
type of Republican vote for me I'm going
to stand with the working-class of
America I'm going to take on the
establishment that's what he campaigned
on at five minutes after he was elected
president he became the establishment
more billionaires in his administration
then
any in American history he told us that
he was going to take on Wall Street well
he did take on Washington he took them
all in Ted's administration he got the
head of Goldman former president of
Goldman Sachs is now his chief economic
adviser he said that he was going to
provide you remember health care for
everybody and he supports legislation
would throw twenty four million people
off of health care raise premiums for
all the workers defund Planned
Parenthood etc so he is dishonesty and
his hypocrisy saying one thing to people
this country and doing exactly the
opposite I guess you know that has kind
of shocked me switching gears a little
bit now to foreign policy you are
celebrated by progressives as being
somebody who was brave in defending
Palestinian human rights and criticizing
some of Israel's policies including the
Prime Minister that's not a popular
position to take an American policy it's
risky about that same time last week you
joined every single US senator in
signing a letter to the UN
secretary-general saying that the
institution is biased against Israel and
effectively trying to shield it from
criticism no no no I don't accept that
look I didn't write that letter I signed
on to know that it's not a letter that I
would have written there are many
problems with Israel and I have been
critical and will be critical of a lot
of what Israel does on the other hand to
see Israel attacked over and over again
for human rights violations which may be
true when you have countries like Saudi
Arabia or Syria Saudi Arabia mark
White's are for women can even drive a
car today okay so I think the thrust of
that letter is not to say that Israel
does not have human rights issues it
does but to say how come it's only
Israel when you have other countries
where women are treated as third class
citizens where in Egypt you know I don't
know how many thousands of people now
linguish lingering in jail so that's the
point of that not to defend Israel but
to say why only is so you want to talk
about human rights let's talk about
human rights should the UN shield Israel
from criticism of course not okay this
letter also denounces the boycott
divestment sanctions movement known as
BDS you in your lifetime are a longtime
proponent of nonviolent
tests this the eyes of many Palestinians
is the effective way to get Israel to
comply with international law and
respect Palestinian human rights do you
accept that no I don't I mean I look I
respect people will do what they want to
do but I think again I think our job as
a nation is to do everything humanly
possible to bring Israel and the
Palestinians and the entire Middle East
of the degree that we came together but
no I'm not a supporter of Palestinians
will say they've resisted violently they
get punished they resist non-violently
with BDS they're also punished June
marks 50 years of occupation starting
1967 we know the occupation has no end
in sight we know that this is a
government that doesn't plan on ending
it and talks have failed for a quarter
century what if not BDS is left for the
Palestinians to do well what what must
be done is that the United States of
America must have a Middle East policy
which is even-handed right which does
not simply supply endless amounts of
money finding of military support to
Israel but which treats both sides with
respect and dignity and does our best to
bring them to the table it's
increasingly evident that hopes for a
two-state solution are almost dead the
at the same time poles among
Palestinians in the occupied West Bank
in Gaza are showing that their
increasingly in favor of a one state
solution with equal rights for Israelis
and Palestinians alike an equal
citizenship is that something you
believe could happen or is that
something you support I don't I mean I
think if that happens then that would be
the end of the State of Israel and I
support Israel for it to exist do you
think a Tuesday solution is still viable
yes I think if there is the political
will to make it happen if there is good
faith on both sides I do think it's
possible and I think there has not been
good faith certainly on this Israeli
government then I have my doubts about
parts of the Palestinian leadership as
well here in the u.s. refugees are a
politically divisive issue we've seen
them demonized by a lot of politicians
and the public rather than embraced the
Trump administration wants to
drastically reduce the number of
refugees that they accept even below
Obama numbers which were criticized as
being too low do you believe that the US
has
failed its moral obligations and accept
the entire world has failed its moral
obligations but I think what the United
States is the most powerful nation on
earth has got to do is do our best to
bring people together to try to hammer
out what its enormous ly difficult this
is not easy stuff Syria is not easy
stuff Israel Palestine is not easy stuff
but that's what we've got to try to do
what would you do if you were president
in terms of Syria in terms of Syria what
I would do is demand that those
countries like Russia which are
supplying an incredible amount of arms
and protection to Syria stop doing it
Assad is a war criminal he is killing
tens and tens and hundreds of thousands
of his own people and we have got to put
pressure on Russia and Iran to stop
supporting this Walker meal all right
thank you
[Music]
you